it's delight of long been sung the Isle
of Capri now they're hard to find among
the throngs of tourists almost every
minute small boats and ferries bring
visitors from the mainland in high
season about 15,000 a day and the island
off the Neapolitan coast is just 10
square kilometers in area
we just heard it's very nice it's a
lovely day we've just been staying in
Sorrento and people say it's very nice
Island we've heard a lot about a campy
and it's been used in a lot of movies
and you know you just hear about it as a
exciting you know get away you to place
one of the most romantic places on
Europe love it that that means two
million tourists a year compared to just
16 thousand residents in the summer
months taking cars onto the island is
banned people take buses from the
harbour or the funicular railway uphill
to Capri town itself
Capri and anacapri are the islands two
towns capris p at setter and small shop
lined lanes also reflect the islands
lifestyle by the turn of the last
century it was a haven for writers and
artists and a resort for the wealthy in
the 1960s celebrity visitors like Grace
Kelly Elizabeth Taylor and Jackie
Kennedy brought it even wider Fame the
then first lady of the US had sandals
made at can for his cobbler's shop the
pre sandals became a best-seller my
grandfather started the business in
these places was 1946 he was the first
one to make traditional sandals leather
sandals with something on like stones
coral be jeweled sandals from that idea
it came what his international known as
a capri sandals it became very popular
because it was the first and the only
one making things like that all can for
a Capri sandals are still handmade the
price for a pair runs from 100 to 380
euros the company has many regular
customers
right nearby are the Augustus gardens
with a view of the vehicle the thirteen
hundred meter serpentine path which the
German industrialist Friedrich Alfred
Krupp had laid out in 1902 crook'd loved
the Mediterranean island's mild climate
and rich vegetation
the carthusian ii also profits from that
some of the capri based perfume makers
formulas date from the Middle Ages hear
only what grows on Capri is used
caduceus creations are sold the world
over including in luxury department
stores legend says that in 1380 the monk
of the monastery which is nearby this
local starting producing a perfume stank
so too and happening queen regina's
Joanna Don John came to the island and
where were as a present were given a lot
of flowers after three days of the
flowers which were poured in this water
smells and this was we say the first
perfume Capri Capri appeals to all the
senses not only are there centuries-old
fragrances there are also flavors
caprese salad was invented here a good
hundred years ago the simple dish of
mozzarella tomatoes and basil appears
regularly on many a menu outside Italy
as well touratech afasy is less well
known it's a chocolate and nut cake made
entirely without flour
well fortified you can then make your
way to the islands main attraction the
quarter asura the blue grotto ancient
Roman rulers are said to have gone
swimming there nowadays it seems more
like a theme park than a natural
spectacle
what's the effective the play of light
comes from two sources first there's a
small hole the boat goes through when
there's much larger one below the water
four or five meters more in diameter the
light that passes through that is
reflected in the water and creates this
dazzling blue color see how that I will
not sue little case of babies sometimes
it's easy to overlook a please natural
beauties in the sea of tourists but the
locals make sure that people at least
hear about Blue Grotto in their souls
Oh